hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the ultibox norway
championship where we again have a game
uh that fits well in our series battle
for the future where young alireza
fellowship will be taking on world
champion magnus carlsen
uh in a classical game and then of
course if the classical game ends in a
draw they will play an armageddon game
so without further ado uh let's check it
out uh in the uh first round of the
outbox norway championship where magnus
had the white pieces their classical
game was drawn but then magnus was able
to win the armageddon game
uh and then now alireza has a chance to
retaliate and maybe to catch up as uh
they're very close
uh like these are the standings uh
currently
uh and as you can see alireza is only a
point behind magnus so a win in the
classical would
get him extremely close to winning the
entire event
uh so let's see how it goes uh alireza
with the white pieces opens with knight
to f3 we have dereti on the board we
have
knight to f6 g3 and c5
uh we have bishop to g2 and now knight
to c6 by magnus we have castles and
now e5 so uh just uh
grabbing hold of the center gaining
control of the d4 square
we have e4 not really giving up upon
because if you capture on e4 you just
get rook to e1
and then well you have to move the
knight then you lose an e5 you could you
could even play d4 and play some
attractive chess
all in all this is something you're
going to do so here the six defending
and the now c3 and again it seems like
you could capture here uh but your king
is still in the center of the board
you just don't want to go for material
and this looks like something that would
definitely favor uh young already
as he prepared for this for for a
classical game of course
so instead uh we have g6 by magnus and
it is uh
already as of move six that we have a
completely new game
so which is uh which is i mean for for a
classical chess
uh new game already as of move six is uh
is pretty insane uh so okay we have d4
by alireza striking in the center
uh magnus still needs at least two more
moves to castle his king to safety we
have c
captors on for c captures and the bishop
to g4
uh putting pressure on the center the
knight is pinned so of course uh
grabbing the pawn is the
is the threat here so d captures an e5
uh
with d captures on e5 and knight to c3
alireza continuous development
uh we have bishop to g7 and now h3
asking what do you want to do do you
want to go back do you want to capture
on f3
uh magnus captures and now before
recapturing alireza trades queen so we
have queen captures on d8
real capture 78 and now bishop captures
on f3
and now magnus just castles the safety
and
we have this position where the material
on the board is completely equal
and the position on the board is also
very very equalish as you can see very
similar
main difference is alireza still has the
bishop pair and magnus doesn't
so here king the g2 improving the
position of the king and
knight to d4 magnus grabs this excellent
outpost for his knight but
furuja will also grab the d5 square for
for his knight
which means that he first needs to pin
the knight grab the knight and then
secure the d5 square for his
own knight so h6 here by magnus and now
bishop captures on f6 we have bishop
captures in the knight to d5 so both
players with excellent outputs for their
uh for their uh monster knights uh
and now uh well well you could play king
to g7
uh if you go king to g7 then we i do we
have like an identical position rook to
d1 is missing
for the position to be uh perfectly
symmetrical uh
but magnus doesn't go for that instead
he goes rook to d6 which defends the
bishop but also
allows him to have some mobility with
the rook you could bring the rook to a6
maybe attack the pawn later on you could
bring this rook to d8 the c8
seems seem just like a more flexible
idea
so here alireza goes to rook a to c1
brings his rook to an open c
file which magnus couldn't do right away
because
well his bishop was hanging he needed he
needed to tend to that and now
bishop back to d8 controlling the knight
and getting rid of the target
we have rook f2d1 by alireza and now
king to g7 by magnus and now
knight back to e3 so as you can see very
solid the position for
uh for both players uh and now rook to
a6 magnus now
attacks the a2 pawn as it is a target so
all it is are forced
to deal with it we have a3 and now h5 by
magnus
grabbing more space on the king's side
we have knights to c4 putting pressure
on the e5 pawn and now
bishop back to f6 for the moment looks
like a weird square for the bishop
but the knight isn't all that impressive
on c4 so magnus says
when you move your knight from c4 i'm
going to move my weird bishop from f6
alright so here h4 by alireza
also just closes up the position on the
king side uh and
now uh rook to c8 getting the other rook
to the open c file
we have knight back to e3 now alireza
offers a trade of
a pair of rooks and magnus's uh not a
problem but we will do it under my term
so rook eight to c6 now
for uh threatening to win material here
so the uh the exchange will happen
on c6 so we have rook characters on c6
rook captures on c6 and now
rook to d3 uh here already says okay i'm
gonna play rook to c3
either i'm gonna get a lot of activity
for my rook or we're gonna just trade
rooks and
uh well i'm pretty sure i can draw this
i mean equal material four pawns uh on
the king side each two
two points on the queen side each uh and
uh a a bishop and the knight each
uh so bishop back to d8 by magnus
now he can shift the bishop over to b6
if needed or to a5 even
and bishop back to d1 uh we rook to c1
by magnus now that alireza allowed it uh
but
bishop to b3 so not really uh
much happening there uh keeping keeping
this rook at bay
not really a lot you can do with with
this rook like you could go rook to b1
but
then knight the c4 comes and you're
defending the pawn but you don't really
have b5 since this point is hanging
and then you have to defend this for
example with f6 and then rook to d1 just
forces the rook trade which is what
magnus wants to avoid so instead after
this bishop to b3 move magnus just goes
b5
and here you can see that alireza
doesn't really have
all that many moves he can play but
even worse than that he is very low on
time uh magnus is like
an hour and 20 minutes and i i think i
checked the game
around at around this point and already
was around
12 minutes i believe on the clock so he
does have to play precise so he plays
rook to d1 he says i want to trade rooks
uh
just uh get or get that rook out of the
way uh magnus retreat
rook to c8 uh he wants to you know lift
the fight another day and now
bishop back to a2 getting rid of this
pressure and he might be interested in
re-maneuvering the bishop to b1
if needed later we have a5 by magnus
grabbing more space on the queen side
and now rook to d3 again alireza with
the same idea he wants to play rook c3
trade the
trade off the last pair of rooks and
play this end game
we have a four by magnus just grabbing
even more space on the queen side and
king f1
alireza says now it's time to start
bringing the king into the game
with bishop to b6 the bishop will be
excellent on this diagonal here
and now uh you could play a waiting move
like bishop to d5 you could play rook to
d2
also a nice waiting move as black now
does have some control of the c2 square
so we might want to play that
however alert is a sticks well not that
but he sticks with his plan and goes
rook to c3
uh offers a rook trade and magnus very
very happily
uh obliges here so rook captures on c3
uh b characters now attacking carlson's
the knight here and the knights the b3
and you definitely don't want to capture
this it seems like you can capture it
double black spawns and also stop the
pass pawns for pawn for example knight
d1 covers this
but bishop to c5 is just a huge problem
for white for example king
e2 you're just going to capture here and
now after king to d2
you will not be able to to approach any
of this and you just
you've just given up too much just
completely lost f5 is coming black will
start to bring the key into the game
and that will be over so here after
knight to b3 we have
king the e1 although brings the king
even closer into the game
and now bishop to c5 so it's a problem
as
these pawns are now on dark squares but
already says it's not a problem since
your pawns
are on light squares and i have a light
square bishop so here
knight to c2 alireza defends it and now
knight to c1
and now uh the bishop is under attack
but also uh the f2 pawn is under attack
and
knight to d3 check is coming so while
you tend to the bishop you will
lose the f2 pawn so by this little
maneuver magnus is
uh able in winning the f2 pawn so all it
is
has to move the bishop bishop to d5 and
now knight to d3
with check king to e2 and now knight
captures an f2 so
magnus has won a pawn but is it enough
in such a
such an equal end game and though he
will start losing the
the the light square pawns on the queen
side so bishop to c6 already
now goes after the queen side pawns uh
and f6
uh defends the e5 pawn and also now the
king can start
coming into the game uh we have knight
to e3
now uh the bishop no longer guards the
knight and the mag and alersa wants to
get rid of the knight
uh so here knight to h1 if you capture
this then it's a big problem for magnus
for example king captures here
and now even after let's say checking f3
now these pawns are falling
and then you have to worry about these
two pawns which which would be winning
for white
so instead after this knight to e3 move
we have knight the
h1 by magnus a very weird square for the
knight but
you are attacking the g3 pawn so here
knights to f1 and getting the knight out
of harms away while also defending the
g3 pawn
and now bishop captures an a3 by magnus
bishop captures and b5
and now bishop to b2 here magnus says uh
do you want to advance your pawn because
if you advance i'm going to advance my
pawn as well and
well your c4 pawn is now blocking your
bishop from guarding the the a2 square
so of course alireza instead trades with
bishop captures and
bishop captures on c3 and now we have
this position where it's a bishop and
knight
four pawns magnus uh versus three pawns
alireza
king to f3 uh trying to trap that knight
of course
on h1 but now bishop to d4 now of course
you need to secure the df2 square for
the knights retreat
we have g4 and now h captures on g4
king captures and now knight to have to
check magnus uh gets his knight back
into the game
king f3 and now king to h6 so magnus
doesn't go
the the other way around uh as this
would take quite some time he wants to
go here
uh via the king side and he will now
start to
do to advance his king we have knight to
g3 not allowing king h5
and knight to d3 now uh we have bishop
to e8 uh and now comes knight to f4
so it's not not easy to to make progress
progress with black but
magnus is banking on the fact that he
has infinite time and alireza has been
playing on
increment for quite a long time now
so here knights to e2 magnus of course
uh alireza wants to trade the knights he
wants to play an opposite colored bishop
end game where being up upon is
nothing so here magnus of course
declines this knight to e6 he says
we will play on it's it's much too early
to draw this
uh bishop to f7 attacking the knight
here and now
knight to c5 just getting the knight out
of the way
knight to g3 and now bishop to c3
uh so still just uh you know wait
waiting to see what happens
and here alireza pushes h5 he says okay
now i'm going to capture here uh
or or you advance this and then i have a
nice pass pawn here if
you play g5 but also g5 just uh
you know runs into bishop to g6 then you
have to worry about knight f5 ideas
and uh you know it's uh worst in
positions like
like these to get checkmated so here
bishop the e1
uh just threatening to pick up the
knight and then win this pawn here
and alireza just trades bishop captures
on g6 we have bishop captures on g3
king captures and the king the g5 so
magnus gave
back the pawn and he improved the
position of his king a little bit
but uh all in all there is not much to
look for here
uh but magnus never gives anyone a draw
if you want to draw against magnus you
will have to play it out
until the the very bare naked kings
so came to f3 and magnus goes knight to
b3 we have bishop to f7 attacking the
knight
knight d4 check with king to g3 and now
knight to e2 with
check king f3 and now knight to f4
magnus of course waiting for
uh for uh any any chance here the h5
pawn is weak and he will of course win
it now
uh king to g3 and knight captures on h5
so the pawn was
in fact a temporary giving back of the
pawn
uh with bishop characters king
characters and the king to h3 and here
we have
a basic king and pawn in game where uh
you basically
needs to keep the opposition to to keep
the black king
king at bay and if you've ever had a
situation like this or if
you if you've ever studied the end game
uh you of course know what we're talking
about here but magnus still says
even though this is a dead draw i'm
still gonna try and play it out so king
h6
king h4 all it is are keeping the the
black king
at bay keeping the opposition we have
king to g7
and now king to g3 keeping the
opposition this is the long opposition
uh because if you go for something like
king to g4 you break the opposition and
you allow magnus to gain the opposition
and now you're just dead lost
for example king of three you're gonna
go king h5 king g3 king g5 again black
gains the opposition king of three king
h4
and now again there's not much to do
here king g4 you will slowly but surely
make your way
uh make your way towards uh towards this
pawn so here instead of king g3
alireza goes for the longer position and
magnus says all right you know what
you're
doing but we're still we're still not
going to draw just yet we're still gonna
try and
go the other way around because okay you
know the longer position on the king
side do you know the longer position on
the queen side
so king f8 we have king to f2 uh sorry
that's not an f2
king to f2 king to e7 we have king to e2
and now
king the e8 by magnus again king to e3
king to d7 by magnus and the king to d3
we have king to d6 and here uh
well here pause the video feel free to
pause the video and try to find
uh the the only not losing move for
alireza a while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting again
the long opposition with king to d2 uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show yes
it is king to d2 you you keep the long
opposition and you keep the opposition
whatever whatever magnus tries king c5
king c3 and so on
however now you'll see something that
happens when
you you're defending you're defending
for a long time and you're defending
against
not just anyone but against magnus
carlsen who is the world champion
probably the
best chess player who ever played the
game and you don't play king to d2 but
instead you play king to c3 and now
now what you've allowed magnus to do is
you've allowed him to gain the
opposition
which is what magnus played king to c5
and it was in this position that alireza
firuja resigned
the game and it's amazing yeah this is a
classical game
already played uh quite quite a lot of
the game
on the increment and you only get the
increment after move 40
but still still this this just shows you
that you always have to grind it out
until the end and
it doesn't matter if it's a draw if it's
a draw but
if uh you know what you're doing you
always have to grind it out
and things will happen and here it
happened here alireza lost the game and
magnus just won
so here what happens is uh white will of
course run out of squares to keep the
opposition for example king d3
now black gains uh momentum king before
you're gonna go let's say king d2 king's
gonna
go in king to c4 you're gonna go kinky
three king c3
again grabbing the opposition king e2
you're gonna go king d4
and finally after king to f3 and king d3
the final opposition
black a white is out of squares to keep
defending the pawn you're gonna have to
move and
the pawn will be lost and of course with
two points it's an easy victory
so after this king to c5 move uh
magnus uh well already resigned and
magnus won the game
and not just in the game but as alireza
was the only one who could pretty much
cap cat uh you know catch up to magnus
uh uh magnus now wins the entire event
the ultibox norway championship
uh one whole round before the before the
event is finished
so this is uh a king and pawn uh two
points against one how to hold this
these are the basics of chess uh but
you know what what what really happened
is it was time trouble and
having magnus calls and as your opponent
and this of course uh
is good enough to take uh to take anyone
down but
just another example you know if you're
the side that's pushing you always need
to push and you always need to hope
uh that your opponent will not play the
absolute perfect game and you will be
able to
to grab uh full three points like magnus
did here
so yeah uh that's uh that's uh the game
i do hope you enjoyed it
uh really really amazing stuff just uh
you know i i i did not believe that
when this happened but this just shows
you that if it can happen to a player
like jalereza
uh you know be sure it can happen to
your opponent when you're playing online
if you're
you know 1500 if you're 1700 1900 2100
2300
it can happen to everyone and you you
always just have to play it out until
the end and you know
always hope for the best so yeah magnus
wins the game he wins the
entire event and he wins yet another
game in their
uh series battle for the future so we'll
see what happens uh
in the next one uh i would like to thank
uh bernard koenigsberg
juan vincenta alvarez uh fair had mechi
making
the judge william and shiv dunda for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
ultibox norway championship checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day